all right welcome back to our exclusive
town hall
with the republican governors
association we're music city usa
nashville tennessee
now what is the future of the republican
agenda how can red states fight back
against the
well biden power grab far left new green
deal socialist agenda
and stand up against the dangerous
effort of defunding and dismantling
police
and answer these questions much more we
turn to our republican governors right
here in nashville
i won't bother you anymore governor
sununu um
that's an inside joke but in all
seriousness here
you all of you can say to the people in
your states
that you have lower taxes that you have
ended burdens from regulation
that you have created business-friendly
environments for everybody
and and we're seeing the benefits of
your policies in place
now all of a sudden you're fiscally
responsible
you balance your budgets you fund your
pensions and then in comes joe biden
with his big blue state bailout and he's
given california and gavin newsom
that has a 75 billion dollar surplus 40
billion
taxpayer dollars from your states i was
a governor i might be a little ticked
off about that governor sununu a lot
ticked off absolutely i mean they came
in and really changed the rules to to
really fit their agenda
um and and what you're seeing is again
governors especially republican
governors are the last line of defense
against not a socialist agenda but true
socialism that's like that that's
actually what's happening with all the
executive orders and we've seen it
uh when you talk about the economy i
think one of the biggest things that
is hitting america is inflation uh
secretary ellen said would have a bump
in inflation we're we're on the verge of
hyperinflation supply chain issues
across this country
and there's no greater tax on the
american people and worse tax than
inflation because
every low-income family has to pay for
that 30 percent more for that gallon of
gas or a piece of wood to do a repair on
their home
or or a gallon of milk whatever it is so
it's um
their policies to help low income and
all that are just reversed
it's all political and what what happens
is they end up hurting those they claim
to be helping the most
yeah exactly well that's exactly the
case and we're paying the price for the
blue state bad decisions that they made
in iowa we're cutting taxes we're
reducing regulations we've had our kids
in school
we are encouraging growth and
development and we're open for business
and it's just completely the contrast
i think he has forgotten that you know i
think he thinks we're just starting
covet that we're not on the end of it
the emergency is over and the amount of
money that's coming into our states is
just
unconscionable and in fact i sent back
95 million
uh they sent 95 million to the state of
iowa to help us get our kids back in the
classroom and i said our kids have been
in the classroom since august
this is ridiculous they're sitting on
700 million right now
to address testing and vaccines and to
help address covet issues and so i said
here you can take the
the 95 million back uh we don't need it
we need to do more of that
um it's it's just unconscionable the
amount of money that's going on
a lot you're trying to take
attached to dictate policy to all of you
that if you take the money you cannot
cut taxes i can't cut taxes
we're cutting taxes yeah yeah wow so
joe biden needs to stop trying to rescue
us we don't need to be rescued
we've we've said that this this money is
really a blue state bailout for the
failures that they've had in the past
what reward you get to be a governor
that actually tightened your belt
cut your budget and lived within your
means i said in my second state of the
state i'd be remiss if i didn't thank my
partner
in growing arizona's economy and that
was then california governor jerry brown
gavin newsom's even been more helpful
and think about it sean ronald reagan
said if the
if the pilgrims would have landed in
california they would have never
discovered the rest of the country
nobody leaves california because they
want to
it's becoming too painful the lack of
opportunity pushing them out
the first time in 171 years they lost
population
and it's a result of leadership policy
and lack of quality of life and economic
opportunity and you know what's even
more ironic
gavin's going to take your money checks
are going to go out to
two-thirds of the people in california
just prior to the recall i don't know
where i grew up in new york
we have different words for that um but
it's but it's from your taxpayers
you think about and you look at the tax
policies and you look at
washington when donald trump became
president
and he put his tax plan in place he got
rid of reductions or
deductions for state and local income
taxes
now personally that hurt me was it the
right thing to do
yes because red states that elect
fiscally responsible
politicians they're being punished they
didn't get the same benefit that i was
getting
now looks like joe's going to go back
and reward his blue state friends
and reinstate that deduction that's
going to hurt every one of you governor
so it it takes from our states and it
not only subsidizes bad blue state
policy it subsidizes very wealthy
taxpayers in those states and so um it's
terrible policy you know when uh
new york you know you and i have talked
about it you guys have millions of
people fewer than florida
your budget's over twice the size of the
budget in the state of florida but yet
and the infrastructure is a disaster our
infrastructure is much better we do
better in k-12
my university system is ranked number
one by u.s news and world report four
years in a row
so you know it just shows you a lot of
that money's being frittered away
but they never make tough choices when
covet hit
the legislature had done our budget and
they kind of crafted the budget before
everything really hit the fan
so i vetoed a record billion dollars
right off the top
and i said look we don't know what's
going to happen we've got to make tough
decisions
well now i look back and like i didn't
have to do that because they're
shoveling so much money
at us and so they're rewarding states
that have made
bad decisions or not been willing to
make tough decisions
you know sean the only reason i ever ran
for office was because of
bad tax policy we had a tragedy in our
family lost my dad ended up paying death
taxes that took me 10 years to pay off
that's why i started showing up at
meetings why i ended up running for
office
when i was in congress i had the chance
to be on ways and means was on the final
conference committee that got to work
with president trump
to to fix a lot of bad parts of our tax
policy in the country
to watch president obiden destroy that
and to damage our country and our
long-term economic system
oh biden now you sound like a talk show
no it does i'm sorry i'm sorry
i don't apologize it's tragic president
biden to watch him undo this is
is tragic and for all of us we're not
making decisions for ourselves we're not
making decisions for the next six months
or a year we're making it for our kids
we're not the ones going to pay off this
debt well i mean we're robbing a blind
yeah you said you mentioned it being
the people's money our money it's their
money it's really easy
federal government is shoveling out
money
it's very easy to spend somebody else's
money
and they forget that this is actually
the people's money um and then
they like to tell states what to do they
don't
much like it when we talk back but
we have talked back and said we do want
to have
that we do want to offer tax cuts we
have had a billion dollar surplus in our
state
in spite of this economic downturn we
we don't want to be told what to do
either with
federal dollars on immigration and what
our kids should learn in school
we don't want to be told by the federal
government what to do and that's really
why
states and what you're seeing here are
beginning to come together and work
together to push back we'll take a break
we've got a lot more to talk about we
will discuss
the issue of law and order we'll discuss
election integrity
what the republican party needs to do if
they want to win in 2022 and 2024
as we continue we're talking to the
republican governors association more
with them as we continue on this
hannity town hall nashville tennessee
thank you for being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else